y'all don't even know I've been feing so
much for a budget graphics card you see
this card has kind of been the budget
go-to option for a while cuz it really
does cost about $200 it's been like this
for probably about a year now that entry
point to even get a GPU at all when you
actually see it playing games uh yeah it
it doesn't really look that great it can
even get 60fps on high settings in
cyberpunk at 1080p that's not R tracing
that's just trying to play the game it
gets 40 FPS I know a big 40 in
blacksmith Wukong probably the best
performance we'll ever see in that game
Horizon forbidden West it's like 40 FPS
too Last of Us Part One it gets 60 FPS
of 108 that's actually pretty decent
I'll give it that one Space Marine 2 it
can't hit 60 FPS though and just don't
even get me started on raate tracing
like why does this graphics card even
support rate tracing it's kind of sad so
this
$220 Intel graphics card the b570 that's
just coming out now gets me pretty
excited and I I would show you the card
I would show you in my hands but I'm
going to be showing you guys some stuff
actually running on my PC in a little
bit so that's where it is right now now
we've already talked about the b580
which you can kind of see on the screen
here but also in my hands this has been
a pretty exciting card too I mean they
freaking sold out immediately they're so
popular we're just so hungry to get
freaking graphics card that's actually
decent value it's it's impossible
nowadays but one of the big things I
want to point about the specs 10 GB of
vram when you compare it to the 6600
that's been that budget card or even the
7600 from AMD or even the RTX 4060 all
of those budget graphics cards have 8 GB
of vam so this card will protect you a
good bit more at least at 1080p from
those games I want to use more cuz most
games are wanting more than 8 gigs
nowadays this card destroys the 6600
okay I tested it in 17 games I won't
show you everything because that's a lot
of stuff to show you and before we get
into the side sides where you can see
the gpus actually running in real time
right up against each other I want you
to pay attention to the number in the
basically usually the upper right where
it's going to show you the average FPS
but then also it'll show you the 1% lows
the 1% lows basically tell you that the
lower the number the more your game is
stuttering and then right below that you
can see the percentage comparisons so
whatever card on the left is going to be
100% which is the Baseline value and
then the one on the right will be either
faster or slower and you can see a
percentage you know compared to the one
on the left and if you do look above as
well you can see all the stats for the
gpus even the CPU I want to point out
though the frame rate here the one on
the left here is the realtime frame rate
the one in the middle is the average and
the one on the right is your 1% lows
however though these are the average of
the last 5 seconds so if you want the
overall average then you can look at the
one below but if you want to kind of get
an idea of what the last 5 Seconds of
performance is then that's the those
numbers up there now if you don't want
to know what the test is then the
settings are on the bottom here in
cyberpunk the
b570 which is technically $20 more than
the the 6600 take that into account I
guess it's 35% faster in cyberpunk at
1080p on High I mean you can play way
comfortably over 60 fps to that point
but then if you add on to that it's 41%
faster on ultra settings and that's
because the b570 has more vram so that
really helps as you up the settings in
the game and it starts to require some
more and next up we don't really we we
don't want we don't talk about Indiana
Jones okay uh that game but then the
b570 is 51% faster in God of War
Ragnarok on Ultra that is a pretty
significant uplift there 66% faster at
1080p in Horizon forbidden West and if
you up the resolution where higher
resolutions also tend to use more vram
it's freaking 86% faster at 1440p I know
a lot of you guys at 1440p monitors are
just getting more and more popular as
the days go on because they're pretty
freaking affordable you can get a good
one for like $200 honestly let's move on
to stalker 2 an Unreal Engine 5 game
that I know a lot of you guys are
interested in but because it's Unreal
Engine 5 it runs like now that
is kind of up to the developers ui5 is
obviously a very versatile engine but
that's for another time we'll make
another video on that at some point if
you just look at 1080p on medium
settings it's actually surprisingly
pretty close the b570 is only about 10%
faster even when you turn on upscaling
in the game at 108p which really sucks
it's medium not even running at 1080p at
that point only 11% faster on the b570
also whenever you notice upscaling in
the games when xss Intel's upscaler is
on actually that's running at a lower
internal resolution if it's an XS 1.3
with this version Intel changed how the
resolution scales work which is kind of
annoying but it might mean that the upsc
performs or overperforms in in these
certain games now I might go back and
actually like test equivalent resolution
scale to get more of an apples to app's
comparison but at this point in time I
just couldn't do it the story really
changes if you just up the settings to
high and I think this might be a vram
capacity thing I'm not even 100% sure
but freaking 39% faster on the b570 like
holy or if you turn on upscaling
again at 108 45% faster this whole story
just gets like it's a slaughterhouse
when you go up to 1440p the 6600 falls
apart if we move on to Last of Us Part
One it's actually only 21% faster in
Last of Us Part One on high settings
here it's actually because the AMD card
overperforms in this game technically
but when we move on to plague tail
requium the b570 is 55% faster Remnant 2
it's actually not that crazy only at 9%
faster but with that that 9% Improvement
in Remnant 2 it actually gets you closer
to 60 FPS and that matters a lot when
you're on a budget graphics card in
Space Marine 2 35% faster on 1080p High
settings and this game does have like an
ultra textures thing inside of the steam
store you can just get a free DLC to
make the textures look even more insane
they use even more vram space Marine 2
just up to
1440p it's already it's just destroying
the 6600 until Dawn it's an UNR Gen 5
game as well and the b570 just to give
you an idea of how Intel can sometimes
have issues because this is only their
second generation of graphics cards and
in that time they've made massive
improvements but until dawn the card
underperforms in that game quite a bit I
don't know if it'll ever even get fixed
I I don't know sometimes the
architecture on Intel graphics card is
lacking sometimes it's just a software
driver fix that they can just you know
do later on but you know that was mostly
just rasterized performance
so I don't even think we want to talk
about R tracing on the 6600 man it's
just a train wreck that I can't help but
look at yeah it's kind of sad how long
this has been the budget card why is it
four years why the are we still buying
this card after four years why is it the
best option I don't know the extra 2 GB
of vram definitely helps in games that
are limited to it because that does
happen a lot it'll give you some more
future proofing it has better upscaling
as well we didn't even mention this this
that much but the xss is a lot better
than FSR and I I don't think the the
6600 will be getting amd's new AI
upscaling kind of stuff so Intel is
making a great budget GPU here in
comparison so hopefully that that bar it
wasn't too low I think the let me get
this the RTX 4060 this comparison is
just hilarious to me so the 4060 costs
$80 more than the b570 that's 36% more
money and when you see the performance
it's is surprisingly close now I do want
to let you guys know that I do have an
RTX 4060 that is very similar to the RX
7600 which is going for around $250 now
the Nvidia card has Nvidia features and
stuff that's how they differentiate each
other but in terms of performance
they're actually pretty close they both
have 8 gigb of vram so the performance
I'm showing you here kind of like
applies to the 7600 as well with maybe
some small differences depending on the
game and let's just hop into cyberpunk
now what's going on there wait the
b570 beats the 4060 in
cyberpunk and this car cost $80 less
especially when we up it to ultra
settings in the game because of probably
the extra vram two more gigabytes on the
b570 and the extra memory bandwidth
we're just seeing that lead grow then at
1440p not to say that this is really a
1440 graphics card but if you do play
this resolution the b570 just destroys
the 4062 but it's interesting in a game
that the b570 runs well and it beats the
4060 Allen W 2 is an Nvidia sponsored
title 4060 you know it costs 36% more
money but it's only 16% faster than the
b570 its value is not really looking
that good here and it's still not
getting 60 FPS at 1080p native which is
terrible from a $300 Nvidia graphics
card cany get an Nvidia sponsored game
get that to 60 FPS at 108 I like we're
only on medium settings like I'm not
going crazy with this at all so if you
do use some upscaling dlss which is
nvidia's upscaler right it can get more
than 60 FPS on that
4060 but the thing is the b570 is
getting close to 60 FPS as well at that
point and it's really like oh is it
really that much better on the 4060 like
it probably feel a little bit smoother
on the 4060 but didn't know what
graphics card was in there could you
really tell the 4060 is 18% faster in
Black Ops 6 which is a pretty good
amount especially if you're a Call of
Duty player Black Ops 6 sweat but it's
only 4% faster in balers Gate 3 which is
not really that much 6% faster at 1440p
so yeah you you probably wouldn't be
able to tell what graphics card is in
there so when you hop over to Horizon
forbidden West what the hell is
happening here in video I'm hoping that
this was my fault I don't really
actually know I thought this was a weird
result and I remember I tried to restart
the game I tried to do all this I
was like what is NVIDIA doing we hop
over to Indiana Jones the 4060 destroys
the b570 and that's probably because the
4060 has better rate tracing performance
which we will look at in in just a
little bit but this is also because
Intel GPS actually have an issue in this
game right now you can see as I kind of
walk through the forest here that the
GPU utilization up in the top left dips
below 100% use Mage like a good chunk of
the time and this is just a bug the
person I talked to at Intel said that
they already figured out the issue and
they will be rolling out the update but
it just didn't come out for this like
early review sample type of stuff what's
funny though is even though the b57 has
a problem here when you do like turn up
the textures in the game which it has
quite good textures if you do turn them
up where you use more vram the 4060 just
does lose here it can be slower than the
b570 which is pretty hilarious I think
now Last of Us Part One also has been
known as the vram hog the vram
basically and here the 4060 is only 12%
faster at 1080p which for costing 36%
more isn't really a good look and then
if you jump up to
1440p the 460 is only 8% faster yeah the
the price just does not look that great
especially cuz I know so many I mean
1440p nowadays would be the starting
resolution that I would just buy my
first monitor at cuz they really are
affordable and it's the same story at
1440p on ultra settings I wouldn't
really say that you'd play it this but
it's only 8% faster on the 4060 then if
you use a little bit upscale you know to
get that FPS in a good range well the
b570 actually beats the 4060 gets it
pretty close to 60 FPS too so that win
actually does matter the b570 also wins
in plague tail requium this just blows
me away and in ratch and Clank the
4060 is 10% slower in the b570 how is
this $220 card beaten a $300 Nvidia card
like how does it happen I don't know the
460s is only 12% faster in Remnant 2 and
then if you go up to 1440p that Gap can
close a little bit more and you can get
both of these cards actually achieve 60
FPS just with some upscaling at 1440p
hopping over to Space Marine 2 baby and
this is actually a rough title for the
Intel Art card again this is one of
those games where it's just a lower
performance than it typically would be
so here the 4060 is 25% faster which is
pretty damn significant okay I'm
wondering if intel will roll out
improvements for this game or if that's
just how the cards run I honestly I
don't know but at 1440p that Gap because
of the vram does close a little bit
which I find interesting and here you
kind of get the story and stalker 2 the
b570 it's a kind of a weak title for it
as well now if we hop over to rate
tracing just cuz it's Nvidia doesn't
mean it can really do R tracing both of
these cards they aren't really R tracing
graphics cards I wouldn't say but it's
interesting to take a look at the r
tracing because in games like Allen wake
2 it's like the 4060 theoretically
destroys the b570 we see the performance
difference here it's the same story in
black myth Wukong where the the the 4060
just kills it but the thing is both of
these games like even with Ray tracing
they just aren't really that usable but
in the game like cyberpunk with just a
little bit of Ray tracing you know just
R trce Reflections in the game which
actually add quite a bit to the game
visually the b570 actually pulls pretty
far ahead I think this is a combination
of vram and also this being a pretty
strong title for the b570 use some
upscaling which again I'm not really a
fan of but if you want to run R tracing
you can achieve like 60 FPS on the P57
the at 1080p here and one of the most
demanding areas of the game which is
Phantom Liberty this whole DLC area
whereas the 4060 can't now you might
think oh that's really cool it can do
some R tracing Tedd so I can probably do
path tracing right path Trac I love path
tracing you can't do path tracing just
forget it okay we hop over to plague
tail requium too with just Ray Trace
Shadows which could be pretty reasonable
to run the game at here it's actually
way closer to playable to play on the
b570 compared to the 4060 like it wins
here and all this performance just makes
me think back like hey here's the b580
and the 4060 we compared these cards
before and hey the Intel card really did
kick some butt here so I thought that
was embarrassing for the 460 but when
you look at this situation with the b570
it being so much cheaper cuz that 4060
is not 36% faster most of the time plus
you get 10 GB of vram it's not a ton of
vram but it has way more future proofing
for 1080p compared to the 4060 which I'm
not even sure if this will be able to
run like modern games in like a year I I
honestly I don't even know at this point
but what you might think is like oh this
b570 is going to be worse in terms of
the power consumption it's going to be
way inefficient because Nvidia is so
efficient and everything what's funny is
in Last of Us Part One I just did a
power consumption test so the total
system power consumption too and even
though like you know the FPS was pretty
close like the b570 was getting 50 FPS
at 1440p on high settings and the 46 is
getting 55 you can see the total system
power consumption was 225 Watts on the
b570 system and then the 4060 was 228
Watts that's the entire system CPU Ram
power supply inefficiencies and so it
isn't wildly inefficient on Intel either
what's funny too is when you look at the
Nvidia features on the 460 it's things
like you know dlss frame generation 4060
only has 8 GB of vram right right right
but dlss frame gen uses more vram you
might not have enough vram to use it and
I've tested it back and forth and the
4060 just doesn't really get all that
many benefits from using dlss frame gem
the headlining feature of that whole
graphics card Generation Now we will see
dlss multiframe gen coming relatively
soon in the future with 50 Series we'll
see how that scales down to these
lower-end cards like the
5060 which the 5060 is looking it's
giving nightmares right now it's it's
it's looking scary the better R tracing
performance on the 4060 is really only
useful what seems like in blender where
uh you know like or any 3D modeling
program it's like twice as fast in terms
of its 3D modeling rate tracing
performance and then the other side is
dlss upscaling on the 4060 could be
pretty interesting right and dlss
upscaling does look better than the b570
is xss upscaling and dlss is soon
getting an entirely new version is going
to be really good from what I can tell
we'll definitely be able to check that
out in probably a few weeks here when it
comes out although xss doesn't look bad
at all okay it isn't the same as dlss
like it's definitely not there but it it
does hold up in quite a few cases cuz
it's also an AI deep learning type
upscaler so the b570 versus the
4060 I mean yeah you get more
performance with the 460 but do you want
to pay that much more for that card and
all the a lot of the features that are
on it don't seem that crazy but one
thing I haven't even mentioned yet is
the b570 just like its bigger
brother the b580
overclocks
soing well it's crazy I will probably do
a dedicated video on overclocking on
this card but you can just use Intel's
like software and stuff and you know
these are the settings that I use for it
if you just want to get a quick look but
yeah on average here we got like 10 15%
more performance on the b570 for
basically free other than you know mind
the higher power consumption on the card
but the card already didn't draw that
much power so I'm not really like that
worried about the consumption the
temperatures are perfectly fine on this
model of the graphics card to the azrock
Challenger did I mention this card
actually looks super cool and it's super
nice so if you're willing to do an
overclock with the you know a slight
risk of damage to your card it could be
pretty crazy I can't guarantee you'll
get the same overclock on your card the
4060 doesn't overclock that well as far
as I can tell it seems to already be
pushed to its limits with that extra
performance the b570 closes that Gap it
gets so close and in games that it was
already close or it was already beating
the 4060 it then just jumps further
ahead of the 4060 and those titles yeah
the overclock is pretty crazy and I
would highly recommend it if you're
willing to take that risk to overclock
this card you can get a lot out of it
yes we will probably seeing new cards
from both of them relatively soon but
they aren't here yet and in this time
Intel has made some pretty crazy
generational Improv improvements like if
we just it's it's insane like versus
their last generation the
a580 had more XE cores on it and these
cards are destroying that card with less
cores they're just performing better and
they're also using way like an order of
magnitude less power than their older
generation cards also Intel is
introduced xss frame generation which is
coming as well it's only in one game
right now it's an F1 2024 hopefully see
this come to more games relatively soon
they've also introduced X which is XS
low latency I'm in Marvel Rivals right
now which I've never played this game
and i' probably mean
Groot and now it's in the game okay I
had just checked this a second ago and
it wasn't in the game but it's here now
unfortunately and I'm kind of looking
through here in Intel software which
we'll talk about in just a second I
don't think there's a way to see the
latency on the computer I think you'd
actually have to do this with like a
high-speed camera or something like that
uh basically with XC low latency if
you're GPU limited which we are you can
see on the upper left is the 100% usage
you'll get just half the latency your
game will be twice as responsive
basically which is pretty freaking cool
we'll see if this uh ends up getting
further implementation compared to like
amd's anti- like 2 cuz AMD does offer
this too but it has been such a rocky
roll out but it Compares a lot to Nvidia
reflex
just not reflex 2 which will be coming
soon speaking of the Intel Graphics
software okay they've improved this a
lot in this time they've been able to
catch up like hey this used to this
software used to suck I'm not going to
lie but now it's really clean like you
can go here you can do your overclocking
all that kind of stuff you can go here
you can change your display settings you
can do an overlay and select things you
can have it show up on your screen as
well and then you can do profiles for
each of your games on your home menu you
can check and update your drivers it's
just super clean it's not even just you
know the software side and the
performance side of these Intel cards
that have caught up so much but also the
aibb graphics cards like let me show you
here was an old a770 model so this is
last generation and just doesn't really
look that good for some reason Sparkle
as a company they went with a blue PCB
like that it is blue you see the power
connectors are blue the PCB itself is
blue and in terms of the build quality
just not the most solid feeling card
ever for sure here's a b580 I haven't
even really shown you guys this but this
runs so well in game it looks so good
like I really like the blue aesthetic
and stuff it's just really cool it's
just such a big step up in the
generation and until it's really
catching up here and that does not
disclude their new model here with the
b570 just the ASRock version of this
card I really like the look of it I I
genuinely do it looks super cool the
only problem with this goddamn card is
how how bright the light
is here we are oh that is a bright LED
holy probably can't tell on camera but
wow it is so bright so yeah Intel has
caught up quite a bit and the main
problem right now that I'm seeing with
Intel cards cuz we're looking at like
the b570 here it's a budget graphics
card which means you're probably going
to be putting it in a relatively budget
CPU system this has been making me
pretty worried hard r on box just did a
another video following up on the b580
he compared it on a new CPU a new very
fast CPU versus an older CPU it gets
significantly worse performance on lower
end CPUs and it's because this the GPU
for whatever reason the Intel GPU has
like CPU overhead problems it really
depends on the game some games are
really really bad in terms of this so
compared to the other GPU manufacturers
the CPU performance on those ones can be
quite a bit better which would be
technically you could get better
performance out of a lower end system
which is not exactly great for the the B
series graphics cards now I have talked
to Intel about this and what they told
me that I can tell you guys is that
they're aware of the issue and they're
working on it we'll see how it pans out
I'm not really sure I'm hoping that they
can overcome this through software
updates but that's the major downside
about these into arc graphics cards
right now but this be b570 surprised me
because when I first saw you know the
price of these cards and they're only
$30 apart the b580 is 250 and the b570
is 220 and when you compare the specs uh
the specs kind of look like the b570
would be about 15 to 20% slower a lot of
the time which just had me worried that
this card really wouldn't be a decent
value at all when we do compare these
I'm kind of reliefed to say the b580 the
bigger brother is only actually about 10
to 15% faster most of the time which
does honestly compare like it it makes
sense in terms of the price increase it'
be $30 more and that's about you know 10
to 15% more money too so the performance
makes sense though the only thing is
with the b580 since you get more vram on
this graphics card it makes it way more
compatible with 1440p games way more
safe in terms of its vrun capacity
technically I think the b580 has a
greater disproportion of value for only
being $30 more so that's why for most of
you guys I'd probably recommend just
leaping and getting the b580 instead of
the b570 but at the end of the day
hopefully you can freaking buy it
apparently they're supposed to getting
restocks here but they have been selling
out like crazy but I think the b570
probably needs to go on to $200 flat in
order to compare pretty closely or make
sense against the b580 from Intel here
that kind of assumes that the b580 is
like price doesn't go up we have pretty
cool stuff I'm going to do a video
probably digging into the overclocking
on these cards I think it'd be really
sick to go into you can get a ton more
performance out of them at the same
price point that g gives a lot of joy to
getting these cards like you get bonus
value but I also have some ideas of why
they aren't you know push the limits out
of the box but we'll talk about in that
video hopefully get your hands on if
you're looking at a budg of GPU get your
hands on one of these I'll try to leave
some links below there'll be affiliate
links if you want to support the channel
but that's been it for me I'm going see
you guys in the next video youall have a
good one and peace
[Music]
sh